[Music]
minor league baseball may not measure up
to the big leagues in the categories of
skill star power and pageantry
but the miners often more than make up
for it when it comes to creativity
take for example some team names like
the amarillo sod poodles the richmond
flying squirrels or the rocket city
trash pandas
so whose job is it to come up with these
this roster of reimagined mascots chris
van cleeve is here with the answer chris
good morning and welcome good morning
jeff this is the work of brandios this
is a company founded by a pair of
lifelong friends going back all the way
to kindergarten from san diego and it
goes beyond just the catchy names their
work has offered a lifeline to many of
these small town teams
baseball is back in beloit wisconsin
even on a tuesday night in the middle of
the summer more than a thousand fans
filled the brand new 33 million dollar
stadium home to the sky cart formerly
known as the snappers why change the
team name new ownership new stadium and
just kind of a fresh start right boyd
snappers in general the brand had been
kind of fading they only had seven
season ticket holders before we took
over ownership back in 2019.
sevens count them on your hands seven
season ticket holders with so few fans
this minor league affiliate of the miami
marlins needed some big league help
maria valentine is the team's vice
president of entertainment we wanted
something that would get the community
excited again about baseball and beloit
it's the only way that this team is
going to survive is if people are
excited
excitement is what these two lifelong
best friends do
jason klein and casey white are
buzzmasters founders of san diego-based
brandios we met on the playground i was
eating paste
i was
baffled that you're eating paste i don't
know let's be friends
their business grew out of their desire
to create the ultimate high school
mascot that's jason in the costume he
spent his college years as big al the
elephant the university of alabama's
mascot while both studied art and design
so we sent 150 letters to every minor
league baseball team across the country
and one got back to us and they said we
like it we'll buy it and we turned my
bedroom into an office at my parents
house
brandis began
a humble start for a pair that has
changed the game one name at a time
taking tired teams and creating a viral
experience that's consistently left fans
wanting more like the richmond flying
squirrels the el paso chihuahuas the
akron rubber ducks the jacksonville
jumbo shrimp and those beloit sky carp
local slang for the canadian geese that
call the city home year round
we wanted people to step into this world
to immerse themselves in this like nine
inning vacation it sounds a lot like
what you're doing is
trying to build a community yeah minor
league baseball has always said they're
the front porch of the community our job
i see is to bring dignity to these towns
the challenge for us is how do we go
into the community figure out what that
story is and then celebrate it by
creating this whole
world
that reinforces that thing that they're
proud of and then you're creating an
experience around that story it's kind
of the dignification of that team so the
idea is that no matter what type of day
you've had prior to the baseball game
you can drive and step into this whole
other world where there's mascots
playing with your kids right there's
on-field entertainment there's silly
names there's promotions and they all
reinforce
everything
that you love about your community and
that it's celebrating some story that
means a lot to you as a local the next
pitch is lined into left field arguably
their biggest success blasted off
outside of huntsville alabama the
ownership group hesitated a lot using
the word trash in their name i don't
want trash to be associated with our
name you can't have trash that's not
going to be a good look it's not going
to sell but oh did it sell the rocket
city trash pandas with their logo
featuring a raccoon in a trash can
rocket ship exploded just as baseball
ground to a halt
the trash panda's first season canceled
in 2020 due to the pandemic we sold 2.3
million dollars in merchandise before
playing a trash panda's game and helped
keep us afloat there it kept all of our
employees full-time employees here
it kept the business from going under
and we were able to get by
what does losing your inaugural season
cost a franchise probably close to 15 17
million dollars but since then the trash
pandas
are a grand slam they boast some of the
highest attendance in the miners and
their swag has outsold everyone what
happened when the pandemic hit pandemic
hits
there's no baseball no baseball means no
fans no fans no money
no brandios
and so
we had to do a hail mary
the guys known for reinventing brands
had to reinvent their own creating an
online forum the clink room where
aspiring designers from around the world
can bring their visions to life on the
80 millimeter canvas
of a baseball hat literally saved our
business it saved our business these are
hats that don't actually have any tie to
anything in reality right they're still
tied to stories and local stories a lot
of them i mean look there's a lot of
puns and a lot of sort of just goofball
fun ideas
and their goofball ideas are still a hit
on the field their newest success is
taking flight back in beloit season
ticket sales are up more than six
thousand percent and in july alone this
beak boutique sold more sky carp stuff
than the snappers ever did it looks good
that's a lot of money for a single a
baseball team a hundred percent it's uh
more money than this team probably
generated in you know five years
potentially those guys out in san diego
are a big part of that right they're the
reason we have the buzz and the
excitement for people to want to come
good stuff
trash panda has got to be
i think the favorite but chris you
brought
some so so the goose has been a hit but
we asked the brandios guys if cbs
saturday morning was a team what might
we look like there it is and this is
part of what they came up with ot sports
who does the jerseys for minor league
baseball rush these for us because
they're awesome guys
i mean you can't have a baseball team oh
without a hat
by the way the sun with a guitar that is
oh i love it
guys
some easter eggs so take a close look
here not only is there a fork in a
guitar but michelle you might notice a
fleur-de-lis there
and guys look closely at the hat you see
there's a bee up there yeah maybe
buffalo maybe boston
buffalo it's good to me i like this set
oh my gosh this is absolutely awesome
very creative stuff please share our
thanks absolutely we'll be right back
and tell you the story too
[Music]
for those of you still with us [ __ ] we
so we were asked for jersey numbers yes
yes and no but we didn't really know why
why so i did 18 because it was the first
year michelle and i joined the show
before jeff was here but that was 18.
when i when i first joined
our show as part of the eyeopener's team
so i picked 42
jackie robinson the museum opened this
year
really excited about that jeff your
number no i i mean i don't really ha i
didn't i don't have a favorite yeah yeah
12 is that 12
jack's 12. well yeah but that's that was
like here's the number born in the 12th
there's a lot i mean there's a bunch of
reasons but like i don't really have a
favorite number i grew up a nolan ryan
fan so it seemed like the right one to
play that's awesome oh my god look at
our controls oh look at the caron kelly
wave and say hi right now yeah kelly our
director is she there
look there's brian and tony brian and
tony wave and say hi
come on yes
bye everybody
so chris you mentioned this while we
were watching the piece one of the
interesting things also with these minor
league teams the number of women that
are that are involved it's such a
family-friendly atmosphere which those
are two separate things but it's nice to
see also a really
women-filled atmosphere as well yeah it
really is
they say that minor league baseball is
the the front porch of many communities
and that's uh that's reflective of how
you're seeing men and women in all parts
of the game now and it's really
remarkable you've got a manager in
single a baseball that's a woman you've
got executives that are women
eventually training that's right that's
right kelly's yelling at me now where's
the b look on the b is